it's a sad truth of tv an otherwise
great tv show can still have a terrible
ending
sometimes it's so bad that it ruins the
entire series
with that in mind let's take a look at
the sci-fi shows with finales so awful
that they cast a paw
on everything that came before the nbc
superhero series heroes has gone down in
tv history as a truly legendary
squandering of potential
for those of you who missed the hype
when it debuted back in 2006
the show follows several different
characters who discover that they have
superpowers they each proceed to use
those powers in various ways to affect
the world around them
for good or bad that's a perfectly solid
premise but the execution didn't always
live up to what could have been
problems include an endless struggle
with tonal inconsistency
weak romance writing and a slapdash
approach to character deaths
while the first season is a whole lot of
fun seasons two and three are
overwhelmingly
messy hero's fourth and final season
marks something of a creative rebound
as it focuses on the characters
themselves as opposed to soapy world
ending drama
the finale even ends with a cool
cliffhanger of hayden panettiere's
character claire
showing the world that she can heal
herself it finally appears that
everyone is going to know about super
powered individuals and everything the
show has promised is
actually going to be explored but of
course it isn't
as this as an ending and there isn't any
time left to do all that
hiro's original finale sucks the joy
from the rest of the series because it's
such a potent reminder of the show's
squandered potential and it's hard to
live with the realization of just how
little of that potential was
actually fulfilled even with the brief
revival series that attempted to fix
things in 2015
the 2000's revival of battlestar
galactica is one of the most critically
acclaimed and popular sci-fi series of
the 21st century
fans adored the story of a distant
civilization of human beings
living life in the 12 colonies as they
fight off attacks from the cylons
the series ends with a three-part finale
entitled daybreak and viewers end up
seriously divided following the
episode's revelations
daybreak reveals that the hallucinations
that gaius baltar
and six had throughout the series were
actually angels
the phrase deus ex machina has never
been more appropriate to describe such
twist as god literally shows up at the
last second to change the fundamental
nature of the series
questions abound to this day was god
just messing with the characters by
sending them angels
why does god give the crew such a
roundabout way of returning to earth
that necessitates
so many brutal assaults daybreak
attempted something daring but it
instead stirred up plenty of controversy
all of this has happened before but the
question remains
does all of this have to happen again
the sarah connor chronicles portrays the
adventures of john and sarah connor in
the aftermath of t2 judgment day
it uses the terminator franchise as a
storytelling springboard and the results
are a bit of a mixed bag
there are plenty of bright spots but
there are also a whole lot of
frustrating moments
the series finale actually manages to be
a decent hour of television in some ways
while the previous episodes focus on the
lead up to the apocalypse
the finale makes it clear that we're
finally about to get into the end game
in regards to the terminator's final
plans
it perfectly teases fans with what's to
come if the show had been renewed for
the third season that the finale
foretells
it probably would have been great but it
never came to be as the show was
cancelled
the finale has become a frustrating
reminder of what the sarah connor
chronicles could have been
and what it should have focused on from
the start there was a period of time
when
all anyone could talk about was lost
even if you never watched it
you probably know that it involves a
group of plane crash survivors who end
up stranded on a mysterious island
flashbacks and flash forwards reveal
more information about the characters
while their time on the island is marked
by strange happenings involving polar
bears and smoke monsters
it had the whole world in its grip and
then it fumbled in the end zone
the lost finale fails primarily because
it didn't let audiences know exactly
what was going
on with the island the show had earned a
reputation for constant ambiguity which
became a double-edged sword
establishing mysteries is one thing but
failing to reward fans for dedication
and patience is another
the finale leaves fans hanging on this
central question
it takes place in the afterlife but it's
also sort of
not the afterlife it's muddled and thus
disappointing
the entire run of lost is cheapened by
its ending why would people go through
the trouble of rewatching the series
when there's no reward at the end of the
tunnel
it's a slog and that's one word that
should never be used to describe
entertainment
alf is an iconic 80s sitcom it stars a
wisecracking alien who crash lands in an
american suburb and ends up living with
the tanners a nice middle-class family
it's a light breezy show
provided you could get past alf's spread
election for eating cats
which makes its dark ending all the more
strange the series finale entitled
consider me gone
sees alf receiving a broadcast over a
shortwave radio
the transmission comes from his fellow
aliens rhonda and skip and
informs him that they've acquired a
planet and wants to create a new home
so alf leaves the tanner's house to
reunite with him alas the plan soon goes
awry when he's captured by the alien
task force
which has intercepted the transmission
alf is now a prisoner
and the episode ends right on that
downer note granted the series did get a
happier finale in the form of project
alf a tv movie that aired six years
later but for quite a while
all fans were left with was the bleak
finale who knows what the authorities
had planned for alf
for such a chip or series it's one
seriously sour note
wait wait don't leave me
the star trek franchise went back to the
beginning in 2001 with the upn series
enterprise as a prequel to the original
series it takes place before
widespread space exploration by focusing
on the travels of earth's
first capable galactic starship it's led
by captain jonathan archer played by
sci-fi veteran and quantum leap star
scott bakula the enterprise never had
the cultural
impact of earlier trek series and while
it was one of upn's higher rated shows
its best spot in the overall yearly tv
rankings was a lowly 115.
the show was cancelled in 2005 and it
sputtered to an
end with a series finale entitled these
are the voyages
a lot happens in this episode commanders
to paul
and charles tripp tucker break up then
tripp shockingly dies as captain archer
tries to guide the ship to one of the
earliest events in the creation of the
united federation of planets
that's all finale worthy stuff but it
came with a twist and an unnecessary
framing device
everything that transpired is witnessed
in the form of a holodeck adventure
witnessed by riker and troy from the
next generation
as a way to help them make a decision
after the events of the 1994 episode the
pegasus
even jolene blaylock who played depaul
called the episode
appalling
[Applause]
the x-files is generally considered one
of the most popular and greatest sci-fi
tv shows of all time
but it had a hard time nailing the
ending after nine seasons in its
original run
two movies and two revival seasons it
finally concluded in 2018
apparently for good with the episode my
struggle four
series creator chris carter told tv
insider that he wanted to tell the
stories of the characters who were quote
central to the mythology agents fox
mulder and dana scully
cigarette smoking man and mulder and
scully's son
william unfortunately the finale is
overstuffed
as it tries to tie up too many loose
ends with one wacky out of nowhere
revelation after another
mulder gets shot but it's not really
mulder but rather william who also
isn't really dead but an immortal
shapeshifter who took on the appearance
of
mulder the cigarette smoking man dies
and scully reveals that she's pregnant
with mulder's baby
it was all a bit much for a show that
probably hung around for too long
when i gave you life i never fathomed
the moment
when i would need to end it quantum leap
follows the adventures of dr sam beckett
over the course of five fascinating
seasons
he's an experimental physicist with six
degrees who gains the ability to leap
through space and time
and inhabit the bodies of various people
throughout history in order to right the
wrongs of the past
this ability comes with a terrible price
though as he can't return home
until he's put history to rights and he
won't know that he's finished until he's
left home
quantum leap's blend of humor and social
commentary garnered a fan base but it
ultimately came to an end after five
seasons due to declining viewership
in the series finale titled mirror image
we learned that sam can return home
if he so chooses but he instead decides
to go back in time and save his friend
al's marriage
in doing so sam willingly makes it so
that he and al
never meet thus trapping himself in a
paradox and giving up the life he so
desperately wished to return to
throughout the duration of the series
his fate is finally chillingly revealed
in the show's last frame
this ending changes the mood of
everything that came before instead of
being a series of wacky misadventures
each episode is reframed as one man's
fruitless quest to return home
he will apparently just keep going
through these motions forever
that's not just bleak it's horrifying
the prisoner is a british series that
aired a single season of 17 episodes
from 1967 to 1968.
it boasts an intriguing plot about
number six an
unnamed intelligence agent who's trapped
in a strange coastal village
it's become a cult classic for many
reasons it's a fascinating allegory
a gripping spy story and a psychological
thriller
its finale however remains controversial
even among die hard fans
the last episode had its work cut out
for it considering how many mysteries
needed to be wrapped up
instead of giving fans straightforward
answers things take a turn for the weird
number six discovers a man wearing a
gorilla mask
whom he then finds out is a clone who
looks exactly like him
yes it seems that everything in this
island has been run by a clone in a
monkey mask
who then blasts off in a rocket ship
it's a decidedly odd ending that casts a
paul
over an otherwise excellent series all
the twists and turns that the prisoner
takes throughout its run aren't as
intriguing when the resolution is so
absurd
the bbc series life on mars follows sam
tyler
a cop from 2006 who ends up in a traffic
accident
he wakes up in 1973 and must discover
what happened to him and how to return
home
in the final episode we get all the
answers we were looking for but not in
the way that anyone
expected the finale reveals that
everything in the series
up until that point had been the result
of sam being in a coma
that's right it was all a dream sam
wakes up back in his own time
but he now finds real life to be utterly
dull
so what does he do why he throws himself
off the roof of a building and back into
his fantasy world
where he can be truly happy once again
the ending is ambiguous
but implied to be an afterlife of sorts
a girl who has symbolized
death throughout the series turns off
the tv at the episode's end
thus indicating that sam is truly beyond
life's tether
moreover the sequel series ashes to
ashes shows sam's personnel file rubber
stamped with the word
suicide it's a downer ending of the most
extreme
sort and a total cop-out which sits
uncomfortably alongside the rest of this
ambitious series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one